hello we begin with the latest
confrontation between Palestinian
fighters in Gaza and Israel which is now
in its fifth day in the past few hours
Israel has bombed one house in baitlya
in the northern Gaza Strip and others in
Gaza City at least 33 Palestinians have
been killed since the bombardments began
on Tuesday Rockets have also been fired
from Gaza in the morning triggering
warning sirens in southern Israel this
comes as Egypt and the United Nations
seek to secure a ceasefire
in just a moment we'll be hearing from
Villa Marx who's standing by for us in
the south of Escalon that's near the
border with Gaza but first let's get an
update from yimna Sayed who's joining us
from Gaza itself so tell us about the
latest airstrikes
yes Dorene well the Israeli airstrikes
have intensified a lot this morning
actually many homes have been targeted
I'm talking about five story five homes
uh three-story buildings uh at least
each home of them uh just this morning
uh in bethelahia in Beijing two in Gaza
City one in and another in ilir mooc
while two in bet hanun and and in
bethlehi as I mentioned now uh there was
a very cautious calm in retaliation by
the Palestinian factions in the past
morning hours but then as mourners
hundreds of mourners were caring and
saying goodbye to iyad al-hasani the
latest Islamic Jihad commander who was
killed yesterday in an assassination in
his apartment in another city as they
mourned him and took him to the cemetery
where he was buried the barrages of
rockets by the Palestinian factions have
resumed towards the Israeli towns many
of them have been going on just in these
past few minutes therein also I want to
mention the targeting of beitelahia
cemetery by an Israeli airstrike that
just took apart a couple of minutes ago
part of the cemetery was destroyed
so do you get the sense on the ground
that things are then heading towards
Morphin escalation or towards some sort
of ceasefire
well the let me tell you about the
latest statement by alcott's brigades
the military wing of Islamic Jihad they
said in front of the continuation of the
assassinations and the bombing of
apartments and civilian homes the
Palestinian resistance will renew its
missile bombardment of the occupied
cities confirming the continuation of
the confrontation and the Revenge of the
free that's the operation called by the
Palestinian factions they also added
that the resistance has prepared itself
for months of Confrontation now from all
the bombardment that we have been
witnessing last night at all morning
hours now the retaliation of the
exchange of fire between both sides they
have these these confrontations do not
show any signs of uh a soon or a near or
a even a fruitful effort of any
mediations towards cease fire and this
has rised the the tension here the fear
among the civilians and residents as we
are going into the fifth day of a
continuous Israeli attack and a
continuous exchange of fire between both
sides thank you thank you for that
update from Gaza let's not bring in
Villa marks he's joining us south of
Escalon that's near the border with Gaza
so Willem what have you seen uh where
you are
well right now I can hear a presumably
Israeli military jet right above my head
just about 60 seconds ago there was a
very loud explosion directly above us in
the distance there is a long plume a
trail from a projectile that looks to be
one of the long-range missiles that's
been of great concern to the Israeli
military over the last few days and in
the last 10 minutes or so we've
certainly seen a couple of the smaller
plumes of smoke indicating that the Iron
Dome the defense mechanism has been
intercepting lower trajectory Rockets
here we've seen warning sirens have been
going off not just in the smaller
communities close to Gaza as happened
early this morning but also in Ashkelon
the city just a few kilometers up the
road and then further up the coast in
the city of ashdod indication again that
these longer range missiles are
effectively getting through some of the
Iron Dome mechanisms no reports so far
of any of the projectiles coming from
Gaza landing on homes or of any
casualties but one thing when we talk
about the possibility of de-escalation
is important to emphasize is the deputy
secretary of state for the United States
Wendy Sherman has been talking she's
said on Twitter to the Strategic affairs
minister here in Israel Ron Derma
calling for a de-escalation in an
attempt to try and Safeguard lives here
okay thank you Villa Marx reporting from
Ashkelon
so the United Nations population front
for Palestine says that at least 417
people or more than 70 families have
been internally displaced by the
escalation of the conflict there are an
estimated 47 000 pregnant women in Gaza
giving birth to some 150 babies every
single day we can now speak to Dominic
Allen who's the United Nations
population fund representative for
Palestine uh Dominic Allen welcome to Al
Jazeera I understand that you've been
usually based in Jerusalem you've been
stuck in Gaza since the latest fighting
in the latest escalation began so can
you just give us first of all your
initial thoughts on what you've seen and
heard in Gaza and particularly what are
the biggest challenges women are facing
as a result of this bombardment
well thank you very much for having
myself and unfp on your show today
during
um indeed we I'm speaking to you from
the middle of Gaza where I hear from my
Windows the Rockets exploding and
getting uh a sense of the escalation
from from right in the middle of Gaza
for for the UN for you and FBA we're
really concerned about the impact of the
escalation and the impact is having on
exacerbating and already very difficult
humanitarian situation this is a one of
the most densely populated places in the
world with a huge amount of vulnerable
people and children
um for us for unfba our major concern is
the impact of this is escalation on on
women and girls like you said especially
pregnant women girls a pregnant girl
pregnant women and domestic violence
survivors this Healthcare System in Gaza
it was already on its knees following
the long term blockade and the impact
that that's had right the latest attacks
have really made the situation worse
right and the orgasms the numbers we
have so far are are that at least three
women have have been killed in Gaza so
what sort of measures then are being
taken by organizations like yours by the
United Nations to protect the rights of
women and to ensure their safety during
these times
well indeed I think all gazans have a
have the right to live a life free of
fear for their lives right now our
concern is about ensuring the the access
to healthcare facilities and hospitals I
spoke yesterday with uh with the head of
the El shifa Hospital biggest maternity
hospital in Gaza looking after those
pregnant women and she's reporting a
reduced number of women coming to build
birthing facilities be out of fear
they're worried by walking the streets
so uh from our side we're working as
part of a coordinated response to look
at all parts of the sectors but for us
for the pregnant women to ensure that
they can receive the support that they
need both access for it for their
regular checkups and and support
supplies that are already major needs
are on the ground so we're here and
we're responding and that must be very
difficult a difficult response though
because it's safe to say that the the
healthcare system in Gaza has been
severely weakened not only of course by
the fighting that's going on right now
but also by by the occupation
yes as I said the
um the the long-term chronic impact
comes uh as a back as a context to this
current acute crisis there are major
needs in Gaza or already existing and
the Healthcare System requires
significant amounts of support for us
we're looking at what we can do to
support the women of Guild with their
sexual reproductive Health needs and
we're looking to provide from our side
the dignity that they require through
kids providing those supplies especially
for those displaced families and and
women that you spoke of earlier we want
to make sure that there are shelters
available for and support services
available for those women who are also
suffering from domestic violence
gender-based violence as well okay we'll
leave it there thank you Dominic Allen
we appreciate your time with us joining
us from Gaza